you'll see a couple of different
fastballs from zach allen the four
seamer and the cutter he has a really
good curveball and an outstanding
straight changeup here is muncie the d.h
look at the miss there's that good
change good start for zach allen now one
of the quiet mvps in the lineup mookie
betts
94 right on the corner and he rings up
mookie vets so here is bellinger now
there's a wind up in the one two to
belligerent he struck him out swinging
got him to chase on a breaking pitch and
a strikeout of muncie bench and
bellinger tony gonzalen 26 year old who
had a sub three era in his major league
debut last year and gets an opportunity
here in the big leagues with alex wood
one on the injured list can tell marta
that's a broken bad flare down the line
to right and
sinks in there for marta bets over to
dig it out marte headed to second he's
going to try for three mookie's throw
right on the money
mookie
on the fly to justin turner who drops
the tag down for the first out and a
thrilling one at that scott peterson
three singles to start the year
here's a one-two to peterson and he's
swinging a miss he struck him out six
outs and two innings for gallon five
events strikeouts dodgers leave one dh
max muncie in the lead off spot tonight
two outs on three pitches for gallons so
far
this one will stay playable again near
the line
escobar wants it here's peralta
eduardo's got it
and zach allen stops out with three
scoreless two up and two down here's the
nine hitter vargas
this one's in play weird bounce nice
play by rios flips behind godzilla and a
good athlete reaches back to make the
play and has faced the minimum
once through the order pitchers duel so
far in the desert no score as we go to
the fourth and mookie bets leads it off
and he drills one to deep left field
let's see if it stays fair and it does a
home run
mookie bets his first home run for the
dodgers and they take a one to nothing
lead
an old world throw in the first inning
and his first home run of the year for
the dodgers in the fourth one nothing la
two one and two out for jack peterson a
strikeout victim in the second
wing in the miss on the change up gallon
with seven strikeouts through four
dodgers up one nothing in the mookie
bets home run two going here in the
fourth and the hitter is escobar did he
go
he did and escobar is out number three
that's the first strikeout for tony
gonzalen tonight who's got four shutout
first and third with one gone is mookie
betts comes up
browns one in the right field for a base
hit mookie mookie mookie and the dodgers
take a two to nothing lead he has
knocked in both run
owen one on turner second and third two
outs
bounced to third base escobar's got it
and gallons trans two victor gonzalez
for his major league debut so the tying
run reaches with two gone here in the
fifth inning the nine hitter tomorrow
vargas comes up for arizona
bounce to short candy hop seagull and a
scoreless fifth inning in the major
league debut for victor gonzalez
[Applause]
zach allen gets strikeout number eight
there once again is that gallon changeup
taylor has walked and singled so he's
been on twice he got midfielded swinging
to miss big fastball that's nine
strikeouts from gallon peterson has
struck out twice over two
lined right to cattail martin old
calhoun as fly down and walked calhoun
rips one down the line that's a fair
ball it's in the corner here comes
cattell martin they're going to send him
in paul calhoun's at second with an rbi
double and two out with a tying run 90
feet away here in the sixth the hitter
is christian walker it's floated down
the right field line bets coming on he's
got it and the ending is over he's
knocked in both dodger runs
check swing roller vargas to second
and kevin ginkel comes in and strands
max muncie secret with two out when the
base is empty 1-1 to seeger it's a fly
ball deep down the right field line of
its pair it is gone and it is gone a
home run
corey seeger it's his third home run of
the year
and for seeger his third home run in as
many games dodgers take a three to one
lead and load the bases for christian
walker christian walker's been swinging
the bat better than anybody else on this
roster right now i want him at the play
with the bases loaded walker sends one
out to right center bets was shaded over
there he can't get it it gets to the
wall martay scores calhoun is home here
comes escobar christian walker a
three-run double
it's 4-3 diamondbacks
and here's david peralta as joe kelly
comes on punched it the other way that
drops in there's your attack on run
david peralta's second hit tonight makes
it 5-3
needs one more out bradley and bellinger
pops it up this will stay playable if
escobar can get there eduardo's got it
boy did they need that